[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDRA BERMANN: Good morning.
STEPHEN MACEDO: Hi.
How are you?
SANDRA BERMANN: How are you?
SUBJECT: Coffee all?
SANDRA BERMANN: Yes.
Coffee would be
great, thank you.
STEPHEN MACEDO: Me too, please.
Thank you.
SANDRA BERMANN: You
know, the whole question
of migration through the ages --
since biblical
times, we've had it.
But now, in our lived history,
we have a refugee crisis.
We have more migration than
we've had since World War II.
And I started thinking
about this community
and the possibility
of having one
in doing my own work on
translation studies but also
literary history and
started to realize
how much I needed to
know to talk about some
of these things in
the current period.
So I went to a
couple of colleagues
and talked with
them, learned a lot,
and started to
think about how much
it would mean to have
a group of faculty
from roundabout campus who
could talk about these things
and, in innovative
ways, share knowledge,
share ways of thinking
about this issue,
and how, eventually, this
could have a huge ripple effect
on campus through our
teaching, through having
student affiliates,
graduate and undergraduates.
And, perhaps, over
time, we will see
opportunities for changing
the public discourse
and developing it
into something that
can create better
solutions or at least
better debates about them.
STEPHEN MACEDO: Yeah.
We probably need to understand
why people see this issue,
you know, so differently,
disagree so widely --
where they're coming from,
what their perceptions
are, what their
misperceptions are,
and how this can be clarified.
One of the things I
find most interesting
is that this is an
issue that doesn't
cut across the usual
left-right divide cleanly.
There are liberals that
worry about high levels
of immigration because of the
impact on the working class.
There are conservatives
that worry
about high levels of
immigration both for that reason
but also because of
effects on the culture
and because of concerns
about cultural stability.
On the other hand,
there are progressives
that are in favor, of course,
of high levels of immigration,
generous policy towards
refugees and poorer
migrants from abroad.
And, likewise, there
are conservatives
who believe in open markets
and open borders, a little
more libertarian.
So these issues
are difficult ones
for both of the major
political parties, in a way.
And it makes them interesting.
Then the question
of who is a refugee
is a central one that hasn't
been all together settled.
It's a disputed category
in international law.
And are people that move out
of great poverty refugees
or merely economic migrants?
A lot of these issues
need a lot more attention
as a matter of policy and law.
SANDRA BERMANN: Absolutely.
And one of the
fascinating things
is the whole use of language
and translation, because what
if you are migrant
and you do not
understand the
language of the country
into which you've migrated?
To have good translation
that's consistent --
these questions have
always fascinated me.
And I think those were some of
the issues that attracted me,
at the beginning, trying to
think about this much more
broadly.
So there are all these
questions in the humanities
that fit into this larger
issue of migration.
STEPHEN MACEDO: I
guess another question
is, you know, what does
it mean to be an American?
And what does it mean to be
French in periods of rising
and large-scale immigration?
How do narratives change?
And I know that scholars of
literature are studying that.
SANDRA BERMANN: Absolutely.
I mean, the question of
narratives and narratives
of migration is absolutely huge
and crosses the disciplines.
And we each look at
it very differently.
But if you think of,
as you were saying,
the narratives that
tell us our nationhood
or why governments
choose certain programs --
migration programs --
then there are also
the journalists’
stories that try
to get very close to the
migrant lives and can be short
or in book form.
And then there are, of course,
all the literary narratives --
literary and filmic,
visual arts, music --
that explore other
aspects of it.
So it's a huge question --
a huge cultural question.
STEPHEN MACEDO: Yeah.
And one of the exciting things
about the research community
is that scholars bring all of
these different perspectives
to bear.
I mean, some people are unnerved
by these changes in what it
means to be an American.
SANDRA BERMANN: Of course.
STEPHEN MACEDO: But
the American story
is one of constant change.
SANDRA BERMANN: Absolutely.
STEPHEN MACEDO: And
it's great strength
that we have an
immigrant history.
SANDRA BERMANN:
It's so interesting
to hear what other national
perspectives are on this, which
can be very different, and to
have people in our research
community who are working on,
you know, the Pacific Asian
world, who are working
on Europe and also
Latin America and the U.S. and
many other parts of the world,
the Middle East.
So it's really very interesting
comparatively, as well,
in terms of region.
STEPHEN MACEDO: Yeah.
And we've got here some of the
best scholars in the Woodrow
Wilson School, sociology,
political science,
in my neck of the woods,
also -- philosophy, economics --
working on both the empirical
and the moral dimensions
of these questions.
And I look forward to,
you know, doing more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]